nel caso vi steste chiedendo come mai
indosso questa maglia color sbocco di
opossum inizia a far veramente freddo e
siccome non voglio ammalarmi con una
settimana scorsa ho deciso di vestire
del vomito di opossum che però mi tiene
caldo degli artisti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo video sono farisei ed
oggi siamo in un nuovo blog come al
solito iniziamo una frenata settimana
questa settimana è stata vinta da sara
che ha fatto questo disegno power che
avevo sul computer da una vita e mezza
forza vera l'avevo già anche messo come
farà della settimana ma sti gran cazzi
allora noi cattolici sono degli oltre
questo disegno che avevo su compiuta da
una vita e mezza ci sono delle cose dei
video che avevo sul computer sempre da
una vita e mezza che non vi ho ancora
fatto vedere e siccome sono delle
piccole clip
ho deciso di unire tutte quante di farci
un video misto a caso partiamo con la
prima di oggi allora ragazzuoli circa un
mesetto fa ho giocato tipo a bowling
cioè io no io gioco a bowling solo sulla
wii vi lascio al campione ragazzi
guardate che roba
bravi grazie bowling fra vige mario
qualcuno style netto siete la madonna
39 amate metti l'indice non metti le
altre 3 il tedesco è esatto intende così
no fai come vuoi
[Musica]
la merda ci si prepara al tiro illustra
la palla
[Musica]
come si gioca a questo gioco delle dei
militanti grazie
non è con il lancio del peso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questo vento chiudete la finestra
[Musica]
lo chiamavano alla ricerca dello slide
e lo chiamavano giusto allora la mia sto
ancora aspettando la [ __ ] che potrebbe
non arrivare perché sono vestito da
sbocco di opossum però ho fatto strike
quindi le cose si bilancia della
prossima clip ragazzi è ciò che mi è
successo un paio di settimane fa col
computer
buona visione buona un cazzo prova odio
questi youtuber che c'hanno la
tecnologia avanzata per fare i video no
avendo io 3 milioni di iscritti da un
computer che sia in grado di dare onore
a questo traguardo
quindi devo avere un computer gesù
cristico bene stavo facendo la copertina
di file knight sisters location come
cazzo si chiama mentre stavo facendo
questa splendida copertina che il mio
computer che in realtà di sotto fatto
grazie finito non ho finito aspettare
che ogni tanto c'è agli spasmi suoi sei
voglia di finire fammelo sapere che io
finisco comprendiamo però per dire
questo rende onore al mio canale youtube
grazie vedi che lo stridore cielo lo
stesso che cazzo mi vesto così a fare la
prossima ragazzi è una delle mie
preferite perché quando abbiamo finito
le riprese di social facebook c'è stata
una festa insomma la festa di fine
riprese che un classico ogni volta che
finisce delle riprese fai la festa con
tutto quanto il cast lo staff
la particolarità di questa festa e che
era una festa in costume ma non solo
era una festa in costume a sorpresa nel
senso che la gente arrivava lì pensava
che ci fosse una festa normale invece
era una festa il costume senza saperlo e
voi vite ma allora se non sanno che in
costume come cazzo fanno ad avere il
costume ci ha mica solo su un portatore
da casa il problema è che arriva via la
festa e ti davano loro un set di costumi
e tu dovevi scegliere quello più adatto
a te
indovinate che cazzo ho scelto io siamo
arrivati alla festa di fine
di fine social games aperto ma cosa stai
facendo salve no ma io non mi sono
vestito grazie grazie grazie
gentilissimo come io non giocando con le
giorgio
ma cos'è questa cosa mi avreste mai
scegli un costume ecco perché quello era
vestito da un dogma o poca dignità di
massa ma non siete vestiti voi non vale
dai dai tu chi sei il kin del liscio io
sono recensiti che censisce questi tutti
ubriachi o pre cinque container ma cosa
avessi perché va a cagare non metterò
quella roba lì non metterò scoprire
grazie a noi ma siamo solo noi ma
riderissimo va bene
[Musica]
penso non sta cosa
mai fatto
bene
[Musica]
trasmettere
zaia ha colpito
me ne vado
[Musica]
perché loro non sono vestiti
sono le uniche due le stanno mandando
veri a cambiarsi la situazione sta
degenerando
[Musica]
rischiando giorni con caldoro ma è un
privilegio
promosso i germi nel parco del
vendendo libertina
ma cosa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
un camion
[Musica]
ecco
io non sarei quante volte lo sogna
[Musica]
costumi a parte surreal tower che si
limona un alieno a parte va bè altre
cose che non meglio che hanno spieghi
assieme all'ultima clip ragazzi che
sempre alla festa di social face è
venuta a trovarci un vecchio amico che
conoscerete tutti però vi lascio al
video che è meglio
niente ragazzi siamo arrivati a prendere
un attivo di break dalla festa perché io
sono ridotto così con questo ma metà
perché sto morendo di caldo e niente
alla festa ho rincontrato tutti quelli
del team è stato superfigo e tra l'altro
la festa c'era anche federico clapis che
è venuto a trovarmi alla festa ciao fede
ciao come stai e dalla vita che non ci
vediamo da il film la gente rapida
l'intera chiesa aspetti 70 metri
ecco così contento insegnanti di più
strano è come facebook ecco 9 spiego
questa cosa da lui in realtà e federico
clapis però non è spiritualmente lo se
sono spiritualmente lo stesso clapis mag
carnalmente non è lo stesso clapis
perché federico ha fatto un'esperienza
sociale ha trovato una persona che l'ha
sostituito quindi adesso è lui federico
clapis non quel mite all'indietro
quello lì non c'entra niente con lui e
federico clapis velocissima club
italiani extracomunitario vabbè io
parlerei del fatto che comunque federico
tutto il tempo per venirmi a trovare pd
grazie vede che l'ex tronista che si
sindrome domandatevi ha mandate grazie a
te facendo hanno capito
[Musica]
hai toppato come cazzo si strappa risate
che tutti sti video che avete appena
visto era meglio se fossero rimasti nel
mio computer che a volte certe cose è
meglio tenerle da parte non farle vedere
però sti cazzi secondo me youtube mi
blocca al video perché surreal powers e
limonata un alieno credo è avere gazzoli
spero che i video vi sia piaciuto io
concludo qui episodio spero che voi non
facciate mai c'è andate sempre preparati
alle feste che non si sa mai che vi
fanno vestire la scooby doo ai ragazzi
conclude mio episodio spero che mi sia
piaciuto e mi chiedo consiglio tecnico
no serio da parte le stronzate per un
secondo perché lo fa sto cazzo di
compiuto c'è qualcuno che si intende di
tecnologie saper che cazzo il mio
computer si apre e si chiude da solo
manco avesse un ernia al disco fisso
però vi sia piaciuto ragazzino si
inserisce un argomento è un mi piace
alla pagina di facebook come notiziare
senza vestiti siete lì ci rivediamo un
posto bello ragazzi